i would scream and help me oh my god
yeah
kyle richards is on the mend after a
recent hospitalization
that's when i'm trying to get the
stinger out of my hand i got it out the
real housewives of beverly hills star
revealed on her insta story sunday that
she was hospitalized after walking into
a beehive at her la home
kyle posted this snap in a hospital bed
writing quote
so this happened yesterday i walked into
a hive of bees and was stung
multiple times if you know me at all you
know i am allergic to bees
and terrified of them the 52 year old
reality star
then shared security camera footage of
the incident
which showed her frantically running
around outside and jumping
into her pool to escape the bees i was
lit screaming and help me oh my god oh
my god oh my god kyle says she's able to
laugh it all off now
but what you can't see in the video is
that the bees were in her hair and were
chasing her
she says her family wasn't home at the
time and the people who work for her
couldn't hear her screaming for help and
to make matters even worse
kyle says her landline wouldn't dial
9-1-1
and claims her epi pen was defective and
wouldn't open
kyle then shared another snap from the
hospital writing that she shared her
story as a warning for others to always
carry their epipens
and to know how to use it thankfully the
bravo star is doing a-okay after the
traumatic event
and she shared a message thanking her
local fire station and medical center
for taking such good care of her
helping her through a panic attack and
quote for repeatedly having to convince
me there were no more bees in my
hair the first responders even came back
the next day to check on her
she shared this selfie writing quote
still looking like a hot mess with my
pool hair and sting marks
hashtag support your local fire
department kyle also
had a laugh sharing this moment from the
real housewives of her co-star lisa
arena
running from a bee wait is happy
but no one is making fans laugh harder
on the current season of the hit reality
show than
kyle's older sister and paris hilton's
mom
kathy hilton it's hard for me to sit
there and pretend like everything's
great
and hunky dory when it's not who is
hunky dory
[Music]
what was hunky dory
is that a nickname for someone kathy and
kyle recently interviewed each other for
e.t
and kathy revealed why she finally said
yes to joining the cast
after asking you many many times what
made you finally decide to say
yes and cave and do the real housewives
of beverly hills
i think you being so persistent
and between getting calls from the
producer and you
back and forth and back and forth it
really does
prove with me at least if you push
and push and push you finally win me
noted good to know and kathy brought her
signature sense of humor okay how much
do you love me
is that a real question okay a lot
how do you think i fit in with this
group of women
i think you fit in perfectly it's so
funny because
you know you already had a relationship
with some of the women
but you got to come in and avoid you
know
all the drama i mean you were there for
the drama but right
it was interesting to me to see you come
in and be like oh my gosh this is so
much fun
i love this what's all the stress for
ladies this is so much fun
right i mean a lot of people would not
say it's fun
well you know me i know how to tune
things out
you